welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spiderman no way home is the
most anticipated film of 2021 with fans
caught in a perfect storm of studio blue
balling
and wishful speculation despite actor
denials that they refused to believe
after
this guy made us all watch him play with
himself crazy and intentional
rumor has it that joining this confirmed
cast of tom holland peter parker
benedict cumberbatch doctor strange
offered molina dock and jamie vox
electro could be sinister six leader
willem defoe norman osborne green goblin
plus
alternate peter parker's toby mcguire
and andrew garfield
and why the hell not the full cast of
knives out too whichever of these
unconfirmed reports you believe
is there even room in this movie for
someone like willem dafoe norman osborne
even sam raymond was like
jesus christ we gotta lock this guy in a
mirror avenge me
so i'm gonna break down all the evidence
pointing to how willem dafoe osborne
could tie into no way home's convoluted
plot
and whether sony's plan will leave us
with some dirt in our eye i'm gonna put
some dirt in your eye
sony recently announced that aaron
taylor johnson would be playing spidey
villain craven the hunter in a solo film
now sony executive sanford panic
claimed that there is a long game for
how they're gonna fold craven and venom
and carnage and morbius
into the tom holland spider-man world
saying quote there actually is a plan
i think now maybe it's getting a little
more clear for people where we're headed
and i think when no way home comes out
even more will be revealed and that
comes right after total film published
their synopsis for no way home reading
quote past life baddies electro jamie
foxx and dr
octopus alfred molina are rumored to
return to a bigger
broader verse that's now reeling from
peter parker's recent unmasking
they use the term spider-verse though
rumored is really the key word and some
would say we're already in a
spider-verse
at least according to the whispers of my
brain from that spider that crawled in
my ear while i was sleeping
yeah the latest rumors are that willem
dafoe norman osborne green goblin will
lead a sinister six team but that's
still unconfirmed we actually conducted
an in-depth investigation of the
timeline of these live-action
spider-verse rumors but here's a quick
summary you're gonna go through these
past jk simmons scamming and far from
home as the j jonah jameson of the mcu
after he already played jameson in the
same remy films though simmons said sony
wanted the characters to be two
different people
kevin feige said after the legal
wrestling between sony and marvel was
resolved quotes
spider-man also happens to be the only
hero with the superpower two cross
cinematic universes so as sony continues
to develop their own spidey verse you
never know what surprises the future
might hold producer of spider-man and
spider-verse chris miller confirmed that
they wanted cameos from tom holland toby
maguire and andrew garfield but that
sony shot them down saying it was quote
too soon jamie foxx was cast in no way
home as elektro from the marq webb films
and then posted fan art showing
three versions of spider-man together
and then deleted it
doctor strange was confirmed for this
film right before doctor strange the
multiverse of madness is going to come
out movie directed by sam raimi director
of the tobey mcguire trilogy and strange
as the primary multiverse navigator of
the mcu suggests the no way home plot
could delve into something
trans-dimensional
alpha molina was confirmed to return as
doc ock and then he later confirmed it
will be
the same version of the character from
the sam raimi spider-man 2
taken from quote that moment of him
drowning in the river
sony latin america posted and then
removed a video
with text translating to who is your
favorite spider-man you don't have to
choose in the marvel multiverse anything
can happen
in spider-man 3 you will quite possibly
see everyone yes
the three peter parker saving the world
together and many youtubers claimed sony
hit their channels with copyright
strikes for re-sharing this footage
toby mcgraw was spotted a wardrobe
fitted in la despite some saying he has
no known major gigs coming up but hey
leave my boy alone a jordan driver in
atlanta
claims to have delivered food to andrew
garfield who might have been in town to
shoot no way home but then the driver
took down those posts
andrew garfield's stunt double william
spencer post and then removed about
being on set with greg townley tom
holland's stunt double
a redditor who correctly predicted julia
louis dreyfus with cameo in the falcon
of the winter soldier but with an
otherwise fatty record
claims a toby and andrew spiderverse
plot leak then what looks like
crew merch for no way home comes out
with a shirt showing andrew garfield
version of the character though some
claim it was just taken from google
images but then also
an official crew cup says save a planet
instead of save the planet which could
tie into the title release video's
tease of the alternate title home worlds
being quote too
boring sony and disney come to an
agreement to release
future spider-man titles on disney plus
suggesting a stronger likelihood of
sharing their ip andrew garfield denied
appearing in no way home on josh
horowitz happy sad confused podcast but
many fans don't believe him saying when
he said i didn't get a call
was him speaking in a kind of code and
that his long rant about the game
werewolf
casts suspicion on him though you could
just as easily argue that any
experienced player of werewolf which
garfield seems to be if he brought it up
would know
not to talk this much if you really are
the werewolf but before i continue
thanks to bespoke post for sponsoring
this video
so bespoke post is a monthly membership
club delivering awesome boxes of top
shelf goods from under the radar brands
every month they introduce their members
to cool new products like outdoor gear
bar wear home and kitchen goods clothing
and more all based on a preference quiz
that you fill out and if you don't like
the box they assigned to you
you can swap it out for another one from
their constantly changing collection of
boxes
it's free to join and you can skip a
month anytime every box has
at least 70 dollars in retail value but
it only costs 45 bucks
right so let's see this month they send
me the filet kit
the carnivore box and you know what that
means
actually i really need a good sharp
knife like this especially i'm chopping
a lot of veggies now
or since it's summertime months i get to
use my rooftop grill with some nice
rib rub rub rub chop chop rub chop rub
whereas this one is the trail kit
i'm gonna hit those summertime trails
whoa look at this it's like a camping
field box
i feel like i often need these let's see
what do we got in here uh
we got a book surviving the great
outdoors
some commando wire saw with some hand
straps
one of these and a sheath
which must mean uh another
ring it's just for like you know cutting
stuff to build a lean too
i'm not gonna murder people in the woods
look i spent many my youth years working
hard to become an eagle scout now it's
finally time to put those skills to work
and go out camping so i can prove that
i'm trustworthy loyal helpful friendly
curtis kind of eating triple thirsty
brave clean irreverent
uh that's right i wasn't kidding about
any scout so yeah to get 20
off of your first box just go to bspk.me
slash newrockstars20 or click the link
in the description and enter the code
new rockstars20 at checkout and really
a never-ending cycle of scoopers rumored
plot leaks on reddit and 4chan
and youtube theories and just all of
these things referencing each other so
much that it starts to feel like
certainty where no one trusts denials
from tom holland or andrew garfield or
sony especially in the wake of marvel
actors like paul bettany getting our
hopes up for one division
get to work with an actor it's going to
be surprise for everybody
i think a live-action spider-verse is
more or less confirmed based alone on
alfred molina's interview
and jamie foxx electro from the mark
webb films and multiverse master doctor
strange being
in this plot but it is still unclear
what exactly they
mean by spider-verse if that sony execs
quote
about this getting a little more clear
for people where we're headed is
referring to alfred molina's interview
or referring to the far more imaginative
multiverse cameo rumors
sony's plan could be some complex
multiverse logic
like for portals to open up and spit
random live-action cameos now in the mcu
similar to what we saw in spider-man and
the spider-verse or sony's plan could be
to follow what they seem to be doing
with jay and jonah jameson
and suggest that these characters are
just already part of the mcu history
with similar backstories as what we saw
before but just with the new spider-man
but i gotta wonder
why else cast doctor strange in this if
not to explain
complex multiverse logic he snapped at
tony stark in avengers infinity war
saying that his mission was
protecting your reality douchebag as if
there are
other realities out there and peter
parker is
super ready for a multiverse plot i'm
sorry
you're saying there's a multiverse i
mean that completely changes how we
understand the initial singularity but
we should also remind ourselves that we
have
yet to see this peter's origin story
only that there was
an uncle ben and that the spider that
bit peter is dead
and that the bite happened six months
before civil war
and i would not be surprised if sony
still intended to
connect that origin story to oscorp as
was their plan in the amazing spider-man
2. the movie that was not exactly fully
scrapped considering they've brought
back a lot of those plot points in
future movies
the biggest one now being jaime fox
electro and now in the mcu based on the
oscorp looking tech supplied by the
power broker and the fact of the winter
soldier i would love for norman osborn
to be one of sharon carter's arms
dealers or maybe the mystery buyer who
was trying to get hank pym's tech and
ant-man in the wasp but remember a
spider-verse does not automatically mean
toby maguire and andrew garfield will
appear as well
it is totally possible for this no way
home spider-verse event to apply only to
past
villains like maybe they're the ones
with no way home
after a multiversal crossover crisis so
while i selfishly want to see
those two in this film i will be not at
all surprised if they don't appear
whenever fan theories get confirmed or
debunked i have been burned by the hype
train too many times to know to just be
grateful for whatever comes to support
this channel check out one of our great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter
eaboss follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you